terminator dark fate has arrived and
it's safe to say that fans have a lot of
questions which works out really well
because we happen to have a lot of
answers answers that require spoilers of
course with that warning let's break
down the ending of Terminator dark fate
the first two-thirds of Terminator dark
fate set the table a new evil Terminator
model called the Rev nine has been sent
from the future to kill a Mexican woman
named daniela luckily someone also sent
back a bionic woman from the future
named Grace to protect her
along with Sarah Connor looking to get
revenge after her son John was killed by
a terminator they end up finding help
from a very unlikely source Arnold
Schwarzenegger's t800 who has been stuck
in the past since killing John after the
events of Terminator 2 the real surprise
here though is that this Terminator has
voluntarily given up the terminating
business and has settled down in a human
life under the name Carl he embodies the
core message from t2 that people can
choose their own fate and rewrite their
future he decided to stop being an evil
killing machine and instead become a
nurturing father figure it's an
unexpected twist that suggests humans
and robots may actually be able to live
together in peace after all if the
robots simply choose a different path
one of the big mysteries in Terminator
dark fate is just why the robots have
sent their agent back in time to kill
Danny
during the final chase scene though
grace reveals the truth that Danny
herself actually becomes the resistance
leader in the future as Sarah puts it
she's the new John Connor the last best
hope for all mankind like Carl
Danny's character arc also reinforces
the idea that you can choose your own
fate several times in the film the
others urged her to run and hide but she
instead insists on fighting back she
chooses to become the hero humanity
needs and indeed it's those choices that
actually make her a hero it's a real
contrast to John who often seemed to
reject the role of Saviour only
reluctantly being pressed into it by
circumstance John as a character seemed
consigned by fate while Danny chooses
her own path
- intent and fight the last third of
Terminator dark fade is essentially one
giant never-ending action sequence that
involves car chases helicopters multiple
plane crashes gunfights and a Humvee
getting swept over a dam leading to an
underwater brawl it's such a whirlwind
of non-stop excitement that you may not
have noticed it's all very very familiar
basically every action beat in
Terminator dark fate is based off of
something from a previous Terminator
installment in a way that's thematically
appropriate even though Sara
successfully destroyed Skynet and t2
which should have led to a happy future
we learn instead that Skynet was just
replaced by a new AI called Legion the
details of the future are different but
the outline is still the same just as
the details of dark fade are different
from the previous films but the plot is
still the same the message now seems to
be the opposite of t2 in dark fate no
matter what you do nothing ever really
changes your destiny in the climax of
the film the whole team of good guys
faces off against the Rev 9 which seems
unfair until you consider the Rev 9 has
the ability to split into two different
self-sufficient robots a metal
exoskeleton like the t800 and a fluid
form like the t1000 the only way that
good guys are able to win is by grace
sacrificing herself so Dani can take
races power source and jam it into Rev
Knights eye hole causing it to melt down
as it happens fans have seen this before
because that's almost exactly how
Arnold's good guy Terminator defeated
the evil TX in Terminator 3 he removes
his Power Core and shoves it in the T
X's mouth whereupon it explodes and
destroys both of them we're not sure if
this is a loving Oh Maj - Terminator 3
or if they just assumed everyone had
forgotten Terminator 3 existed at all
either could be true but the Power Core
delivered to the rev nines head there's
just one last thing that needs to happen
a sad descent into the pit where both
the villainous Rev 9 and the heroic t800
model known as Carl blink their final
blinky lights it's sad or at least it's
supposed to be sad because it's very
intentionally calling back memories of
the infamous ending
t-too you remember that one right it's
the one with the thumbs up it's obvious
director Tim Miller is helping the
memory of t2s tearjerker ending will add
some much-needed gravitas to the climax
of terminator dark fate Avengers endgame
isn't the only action movie this year
that gets its emotional resonance from
the films that came before I love you
please have faith that's not the final
moving moment designed to play on
people's emotions though the final scene
of terminator dark fate is designed to
deliver a double subliminal whammy to
anyone who has seen terminator and T to
Danny and Sarah Connor are at a
playground where they watch a young and
oblivious grace playing with her family
after Danny vows to make sure grace
doesn't have to sacrifice herself she
and Sarah jump in a waiting vehicle and
drive off to prepare for the impending
Armageddon the playground element of
course is a clear reference to the
infamous playground scene in t2 where
Sarah Connor and watches families get
incinerated by the Skynet caused nuclear
holocaust and the riding into the sunset
ending is exactly the same as the end of
the first Terminator film only this time
instead of being pregnant with the
future savior of humanity that she has
to Train Sarah Connor is riding shotgun
with her structurally Terminator dark
fate is almost identical to the original
Terminator film in much the same way
that Star Wars Episode 7 the force
awakens was a soft reboot of the
original Star Wars Episode 4 a new hope
so we actually have a pretty good idea
where they could go with the next film
in the series a new version of t2 sure
the plot would actually have to be
different but the main thrust of t2 was
the attempt to prevent Armageddon by
destroying Skynet in dark fate they
don't ever have the chance to even think
about stopping the apocalypse but they
could certainly try to take steps in
Terminator 7 to prevent the new AI
Legion from coming to be one thing is
for sure we can't wait to find out which
beloved scenes from the previous
Terminator films they'll remake in the
next one
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss
Ingle one
[Music]